欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,这一小节我们来讲一下关于RTS店铺和定制店铺怎么样做差异化运营
让我们的询盘质量更好,询盘增长更快
那么在操作店铺的过程中,很多人不分RTS店铺和定制店铺,就是瞎操作一通
最后面导致要么就是询盘质量不高,导致转化率很低
要么就是询盘很多,但是转化很少,订单很少,这种情况
因为他没有按照具体的店铺, 具体的操作都是乱来的
那么不同的赛道的店铺呢, 侧重的方向和资源都是不一样的
首先我们来看一下定制店铺怎么样去操作
定制店铺里面最多链接一定是定制产品的链接
可能要占到70%以上的链接
而30%是铁齿链接
那么在这个板块呢
定制链接主要是获取询盘
第二个就是定制链接所获取的板块的买家的人群是不一样的
也就是在国际站上面是不是有两个流量入口
一个是产品入口,一个是供应商入口
这两个板块对应着不同的买家群体
如果你做定制店铺流量都是来自于一些榜单啊
或者是一些RTS流量的场景的话
那么你的整个店铺的这类人群的需求度以及它的起定量都是比较低的
所以说你做定制店铺就跟这一类人群就是不匹配的
所以你在运营店铺的时候一定要侧重在定制链接上发力
把你的订单跟询盘全部集中在定制链接为主
然后RTS也要去打造30%左右的链接
去获取部分RTS场景板块的买家群体
这样的话你的店铺的总流量才能够更大
而且是你的人群会更加精准
你的询盘质量会更高
订单转化更高
不然的话你做定制店铺全部来的都是RTS的买家
那么你是很难成交大订制类的订单的
在价格跟起定量上面
它们就是天差地别的一个差距
所以一定要区分好
那么你在定制店铺里面也要保证一定的RTS比例, 同时要保证部分RTS的链接非常的强悍, 能够进入到首页这些核心的板块去获取流量
这里面RTS里面的部分买家也是有高质量的, 所以说这个板块也不能放弃
第二种就是RTS的店铺, RTS的店铺里面RTS的链接要占到70%以上
把你所有店铺的流量资源重点倾斜在这个RTS链接上面
比如说这个RTS链接更加侧重就是循环加订单加买家数
所以你要想办法去提升买家数为主
也就是订单量为主
比如说你想让你的RTS进入更多的榜单
或者是说报名更多的活动
你这个RTS的链接一定要非常非常好
一定要集中大量的订单跟买家数
那么只要你店铺里面报了一到三款或者更多的链接之后
那么你的整个店铺的总流量一定会突飞猛进
这个是已经被验证过的
而且大部分人做RTS的店铺流量都会比做定制店铺的流量大
为什么呢
因为RTS店铺的流量来源多于定制店铺的流量来源
因为在APU端RTS的引流入口非常的多
所以说它的天然的整体的流量就大于你这个定制店铺的总体的流量
所以这两个没有办法一一的对比的
我们要看的是分开来看每个类型的店铺看什么指标
以及每个类型的店铺去侧重哪些指标的提升
这样就可以了
因为这两个店铺的类型所需要获取的买家类型
是不一样的,他们的店铺标签以及他们的转化率都是不一样的,因为我们的客户群体不一样,我们的产品可能本身就不一样,所以你在做店铺的时候一定要做一点差异化运营,不要全部都是不知道你的资源要往哪个方向倾斜,你只有分清了这个方向之后,那么你所有的操作动作都会在一个正确的方向上持续的积累,
就一定能够提升整个店铺的总油量
那么这节课我们就讲到这里
希望能够帮助你区别的对待这两种类型的店铺
下节课我们再见